- [Mikhail] Hi, this is Mikhail.
- Mikhail, this is
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Mikhail] God dammit, Gary.
(group laughter)
("Legendary" by Welshly Arms)
What if I told you
this was the last
Monday morning of your life?
- [Gary] Should I call some
people randomly right now?
I always love that.
- [Nate] I was gonna come in
town regardless this week
and go to the Suns game.
- [Gary] What's your number?
That's my tweet.
(conference phone dialing)
People just tweeting
their number.
I mean, like, a lot.
(phone ringing)
- [Jon] Did you literally just
say give me your phone number?
(phone ringing)
- [DRock] Is this Chad?
- Wait, go up to your tweet.
(phone ringing)
- [Chad] Good afternoon.
- Good afternoon Chad,
it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Chad] GaryVee,
I don't believe you.
- You better fuckin' believe it,
man, I'm just saying what's up.
- [Chad] I don't
fucking believe this.
(group laughter)
- How you doin'?
- [Chad] I'm doing
pretty good, Gary.
You don't understand.
Me, my co-founders, man,
we like whenever shit sucks,
we're like yo, you know what?
We need to go catch
up on some GaryVee.
(group laughter)
It's like everyday.
- I appreciate it, man.
Listen, I hope you
have a great weekend.
You guys are in D.C.?
- [Chad] Yeah, we're in D.C.
My co-founder, Steve
is on the line, too.
- What up, Steve?
- [Chad] Both of us
are from New York.
- [Steve] What's
going on GaryVee?
- All good.
- [Chad] Hey man.
- Thank you, my man.
- [Chad] We're
both from New York.
- [Steve] I hate to cut
you off Chad but Gary
one point of contention.
I am not a Jets fan.
- Are you a Giants fan?
- [Steve] I'm a
Giants fan, brother.
(Gary hangs up the phone)
- [Group] Oh!
(group laughter)
- Sorry, Steve.
They're literally
on the line like...
(group laughter)
Alright, let's go
to somebody else.
- [DRock] That guy
doesn't know why the fuck.
- This is gonna be a
story they tell forever.
Alright, AJ time.
- [AJ] Hello!
- AJ.
- [AJ] Hey, man, what's up?
- Life is good.
How are you?
- [AJ] I'm great man.
- What happening in
Skippack, Pennsylvania?
- [AJ] What's
happening in Pennsylvania?
Nothing much man.
Just got done teaching
some kids some basketball.
- I love it.
How'd they play?
- [AJ] We won.
Got our first W.
- What was the score?
- [AJ] We won by 20 actually.
- I love it.
I love it, AJ.
- [AJ] I know, I know man.
How's everything
going with you, man?
Life is good man, just calling
some people and saying what's up
and trying to give some love.
You have a great weekend.
- [AJ] Yeah, man, you too.
- Take care.
You got it.
- [Tyler] Go State.
(dial tone)
- 1480-272...
Scott Cones.
(phone ringing)
- [Scott] Hello?
- Scott?
- [Scott] This is Scott.
- This is Gary.
- [Scott] No way!
(group laughter)
- How are you, man?
- [Scott] Oh my God,
you sound like you.
I'm freaking out.
(group laughter)
- Scott, this is not somebody
tricking you using my voice.
This is me, man.
How are you?
- [Scott] Ah!
I am so stoked.
This is amazing.
- Scott, I'm calling you to
tell you that you have
38 people that follow you
and you're following
38 people on Twitter so now
I'm following you
so you have one
more follower than
people you follow.
- [Scott] One thing I want to
know because I'm a pastor so
what should the
Church be doing better?
- Wooo!
(group laughter)
You're laying it on thick.
- [Scott] Man, I got
to learn from the best.
(inaudible) I got to do
things nobody else is doing.
- Well then you need to put out
your message not just within the
four walls of the
Church but throughout
the four walls of Earth, right?
Look what's happening right now.
You and I are having
this personal connection.
This means something and it's
being done through technology so
use technology to
accomplish what you want.
Whether that's to raise
money for kids that
are underprivileged,
whether that's to get
more people into the Church,
whether that's to
sell baseball cards,
use the technology that reaches
people that is current today.
Do not be romantic about
how it was done before.
- [Scott] Awesome.
Thank you, thank you.
Thank you, Gary.
- You're welcome, man.
I hope you have
a great weekend.
- [Scott] You too, man.
Have a good day.
- Bye-bye.
GaryVee just hung up on me
because my asshole co-founder
LLCoolZay is a
fucking Giants fan.
(group laughter)
Hold on,
hold on, hold on.
- [Jon] You should
call him back.
- This is true.
I'm just sitting here
randomly calling people
on Twitter and
this happened to Chad.
Chad, I'm sorry, man.
I loved you.
- [Nate] I loved you.
(group laughter)
- That's the best part.
He's gonna listen
to that second part.
Did he say love or loved?
(group laughter)
(dial tone)
Somebody's calling back.
(phone ringing)
Oh no, it's not.
I'm sorry.
(phone ringing)
- [Oliver] Hello?
- Oliver?
- [Oliver] Yes, sir.
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Oliver] Hey Gary.
- How are you, man?
- [Oliver] Holy cow!
Dude, oh my God!
- How you doin'?
- [Oliver] Dude, I'm doing good.
I just had a really bad day
and love your stuff and
it's getting me fired up, man.
- Well, I love it man.
I'm glad we're
connecting on a tough day.
There's lots of them.
I hope this random thing brings
a little bit of happiness to you,
sets you into the
weekend in a good way.
- [Oliver] Man...
- Cool, man, well listen, I hope
you have the best weekend and
I'm glad we had this moment.
- [Oliver] Keep hustlin'.
- I will.
You too, man.
- [Oliver] I'll see
you at the top, brother.
- I can't wait.
Hurry up.
- [Oliver] I love you, Gary.
- Actually, don't hurry up.
Patience.
(group laughter)
(dial tone)
- [DRock] That was awesome.
(phone ringing)
- Hello?
- [Woman] Hello, yes?
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Woman] Shut your mouth.
(group laughter)
- It's me.
- [Woman] (laughs)
I thought I was crazy.
- You're not crazy.
I might be crazy but you
are definitely not crazy.
- [Woman] Holy shit.
Holy shit.
Merry Christmas.
- Thank you so much.
Merry Christmas to you.
How's Dallas, Texas?
- [Woman] It got a little cold.
I can't believe...I'm
losing my fucking mind.
(group laughter)
- Well, listen, I want to call a
couple more people before I have
to go to this meeting and I hope
you have a great weekend and
I'm glad we got to connect.
- [Woman] Thank you,
thank you so much.
You motivated me just
from the phone call.
- I love it.
Good, take care.
Bye-bye.
- [Phil] The holy shoot.
- I was just about to say, she
said, "Holy shoot," and
then she went there.
What, somebody's calling people?
That's so ridiculous.
(dial tone)
I hate when people
take good things and
do bad things with it.
- [Jon] Somebody's
calling phone numbers?
- [DRock] What are
we doing here, Gary?
- Just bringing some
value, scaling the unscalable.
You know, if Keyshawn Johnson
or Al Toon called me randomly
20 years ago I would
have never forgotten it.
- [Jon] Absolutely.
- [Nashita] Hello?
- Hey, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
Nashita?
- [Nashita] You're kidding.
- I'm not kidding.
(laughs) Are you still there?
I'm not kidding.
- [Nashita] Of course!
Oh my God!
- How are you?
- [Nashita] Light of my life.
- Well, I mean,
thank you so much.
How's it going?
- [Nashita] I can't
believe I'm talking to you.
(group laughter)
- Well it's happening,
we're talking.
- [Nashita] Tell me
what I need to do.
I will do anything.
I will work for you for free.
I don't want your money.
I don't want anything,
I just want to be on your team.
- Well, you know
what you should do?
Then you should send me an
email and we should talk.
Tell me what you do.
- [Nashita] I email
you every day.
- Oh, I know
exactly who you are.
I know exactly who you are.
- [Nashita] Oh my God!!!
Yes!
- I'm so glad we're connecting.
- [Nashita] I will
be on your team.
I know that GaryVee,
I will be on your team.
- I love it.
Well, I'll talk to
you soon, okay?
- [Nashita] Yes!
(Gary laughs) I love you, I love
you, I love you, I love you!
- Thank you.
Have a good night.
This is the point.
It's so funny.
We'll talk a
little bit about that.
I wish people actually knew.
I wish our clients actually knew
or people that I do business
with actually knew what's
actually happening and
how easy it can
be for me and
how right what I'm doing is.
People don't get it.
(phone ringing)
Do you know how
easy this is now for me?
I could cruise into the sunset.
Easily, make lots of money.
- [Tim] Hello?
- Yo, Tim!
- [Tim] Hey.
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Tim] Hey, what's up, Gary?
- How are you?
- [Tim] Doing good.
How are you?
- Dude, your beard is
fucking unbelievable.
- [Tim] Thanks man.
- No worries, man.
How's life?
- [Tim] This is crazy.
- Are you in Denver?
- [Tim] Yeah, yeah.
I live close to Denver, yeah.
- Awesome, man.
- [Tim] Life's good, man.
- Good man.
I appreciate you following my
stuff and putting out your phone
number and allowing me to say
thank you for your attention.
- [Tim] Oh, yeah, man
I appreciate everything
you post, man. It's...
- The best?
- [Tim] a great way to
use social media I guess.
- Thanks man, I appreciate it.
Are you a Broncos fan?
- [Tim] You know man--
- You don't give a
shit about football.
- [Tim] I don't watch
a lot of football, no.
- Can you be a Jets fan then?
- [Tim] Sure.
- Yes!
- [Tim] I'll jump on
the Jets bandwagon.
- One at a time, baby.
Timmy, have a great weekend man.
Thank you so much for the love.
- [Tim] Thanks man, you too.
- Alright man, talk to you.
Gonna call every person on
Earth and make them a Jets fan.
(group laughter)
When I buy the
Jets this is what I'm gonna do
for the first four years.
(phone ringing)
This one's gonna be good.
- [Nate] Way more
Instagram followers.
- [Jamal] Yes, hello?
- Hello, this is
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Jamal] Yeah.
Yes, hello?
- Hey, this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Jamal] Holy smokes, Gary!
- What up, man?
- [Jamal] Holy shit!
What's up?!?
(group laughter)
- What's up, baby?
- [Jamal] Holy shit.
Gary called me.
Oh, my God.
Holy smokes!
Oh my God, dude, oh my God.
Man, I just want to figure out
how I can just like I've been
doing Twitter for a while and
I've been trying to figure out
how I can make
money at this thing.
(group laughter)
I give love to everyone.
I show everybody love.
I do all the stuff you
say and it's like people
never give me love.
Sometimes they do--
- I'm giving you love right now.
- [Jamal] Dude, I'm in shock.
I'm like holy shit.
Who is this calling
me from California?
Oh my God. (mumbles)
I swear to God, I'm in Chicago
right now I'm gonna go on
Twitter like yo dude,
Gary Vaynerchuk
like he called me.
I'm in shock.
Wow!
- Yo, what's your name?
- [Jamal] My name is Jamal.
Jamal Summerell.
I go by JamsRide on Twitter.
- I see that.
JamsRide The Vibe, baby.
- [Jamal] Same thing,--
- @JamsRide.
Watch this Jamal, everybody
watching this on DailyVee go
follow @JamsRide on Twitter.
That's real love, Jamal and
Vayner Nation will step up for
you man.
- [Jamal] Oh wow,
I appreciate it so much, man.
- And Jamal, real quick, real
quick 'cause I want to call a
couple other people before
I got to do what I got to do.
You've got to have something to
deploy against, if you're gonna
make money, you have
to sell something.
That's the biggest
mistake young hustlers make.
They just think social media,
social media followers
don't mean anything.
You have to have
something to sell.
- [Jamal] Right.
But I don't sell
anything personally.
- Well that's why
nobody's giving you money.
(laughs)
- [Jamal] (laughs) Right.
(group laughter)
Exactly.
I want to help market other
products and stuff like that.
- Well then listen, when I got
to your Twitter profile it can't
go to LevelNextMusic.com.
It needs to go to a blog that
has you as a marketer that has a
$500 a day rate for
marketing and social media.
You got to put yourself in a
position to get the money that
you're looking for.
- [Jamal] Got it.
So I need to start a blog then.
Is that message?
- It's not that simple.
You have to position yourself
when people find you on social,
when they click that URL you're
sending me to a music site.
- [Jamal] Right, well that's
because that's our record label.
- Got it.
- [Jamal] I need to
have a different URL--
- If you want people
to hire you to do that,
that's where you
need to send them.
Right now, you're
sending them to music so
that's how it works out.
You get attention you
send them somewhere.
You're now getting attention
from this engagement but
you're sending it to
something different.
I don't need a record label but
maybe I needed somebody to help
me market my pizza shop for $500
for the day and maybe it was
Jamal but my problem is I'm
sent to a God damn music site.
- [Jamal] (laughs)
I appreciate that, Gary.
- No worries, man.
- [Jamal] Is there certain,
do you suggest
certain blogs that do that?
Starting point?
- I think you got to get a
Wordpress or a Squarespace and
create a landing page where
people can see
what you're offering.
You got to just
articulate what you're offering.
Make a Medium post and
just write it in there.
Tell them what you're doing.
- [Jamal] Got it.
- Got it?
Thanks so much.
- Alright man, good night.
Peace and blessings, brother.
- Take care, my man.
Well they don't curse at first
but the second statement is just
(laughs) straight fire.
(dial tone)
(phone ringing)
- [Nathaniel] Hello?
- Nathaniel?
- [Nathaniel] That's, oh my God!
(group laughter)
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Nathaniel] Oh my God!
- How are you?
Can I call you Nate?
- [Nathaniel] Yeah,
call me Nate, that's fine.
- Good.
How are things?
- [Nate] They're great
now, I'll tell you what.
Oh my God.
- You know, Nate you said
that you thought you were gonna
regret putting out
your phone number.
I think we've changed that and
now I think you're
pumped you did it.
- [Nate] Yeah,
I'm pretty pumped.
I'm not gonna lie.
- So, what's up man?
- [Nate] Gonna have to
delete that tweet though.
Not staying out
there, that's for sure.
- Go ahead.
No problem. You do you.
How are things?
- [Nate] They're great, Gary.
Can I ask you a question?
- Of course.
- [Nate] So I tweeted at you a
couple of days telling that you
inspired me to take on
my first freelance writing gig.
- Okay.
- [Nate] And I actually
completed that today and the
client paid me 10 bucks but she
left me this one-and-a-half star
review and didn't leave
any comments or feedback.
I'm struggling to jump
back from that, you know?
- Well, great.
Then I came to you
at the perfect time.
Fuck her!
- [Nate] What?
- (laughs) Meaning who gives
a shit what she said, right?
It's only one customer there's
plenty of people who don't think
what I do is good or
they didn't like it.
You're gonna
bounce back tomorrow.
We're going right back at it and
the next person's gonna love it.
- [Nate] Hell yeah!
- And more importantly we're
gonna go back at it tomorrow and
the next person's gonna leave a
one star review and say you suck
and we're gonna go
back at it the next day.
- [Nate] (sighs) Dude, Gary,
I'm just freaking
out too much to
even talk to you or
anything but like, man, that...
That pumps me up.
- Good, man.
- [Nate] I was reading, my
mentor's named Aaron Orendorf
and he was
mentioning on his blog
talking about let's get rejected
and that's his big
slogan and dude, I hear ya.
- Dude, you accomplished it.
You got rejected
and you got paid.
That's like a double win.
Let's move on.
- [Nate] (sigh of relief)
Gotta tell you my
heart's racing though.
I'm gonna let you go Gary.
I'm sure a lot of other people
want to hear from you, too.
- My man, I'm super glad we
had this moment together.
Always remember it.
Let's move forward, okay?
- [Nate] Alright, thanks Gary.
- Take care, pal.
Man.
- [Phil] Fuck.
- [Nate] You got to stop Gary
from doing this because he's
gonna want to do
it an hour an day.
- [Phil] Be careful.
- Be careful this is
my favorite thing.
(phone ringing)
- [Alex] Hello?
- Alex?
- [Alex] Yeah.
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Alex] Oh my God.
- How are you?
- [Alex] Dude, what's up?
- Life is good.
- [Alex] I'm good,
How are you?
- What's happening?
- Because, I trying
really hard for you
to get you to call me.
- It worked.
- [Alex] I know it did.
Which one did work?
The one I replied on?
Or the one I just sent
to you just now?
- The one you just
sent right now
with the emojis
with the red phones.
- [Alex] Oh, dude, awesome.
(Gary laughs)
- Where do you live?
- Where do I live?
- Yeah.
- [Alex] In Florida, in Tampa.
- Nice, man, how's Tampa?
- [Alex] It's good.
It's cold today.
It's like 56 degrees.
- 56 is warm in Belarus.
- I know. I know but
I'm accommodated here.
- I get it, brother.
I got a couple--
- [Alex] Oh, man, dude
my heart is like pumping
out of my chest right now.
- I'm flattered, man.
Life is good?
What are you up to?
What do you do?
What's your thing?
- [Alex] I work full-time.
I go to school full-time.
And I'm just
hustling outside of that.
I just got my school done
so right now I'm
literally sleeping for
about four hours a day
and working for about 18.
Not even talking to anybody,
not talking to my friends,
not doing anything.
I'm just dedicated, I'm
focused and almost all that
a lot of it is
due to you, for real.
- Thank you, man,
how's it goin--
- [Alex] All I do--
I stopped listening to music.
I just listen to the
DailyVee all day.
- Well I appre--
- [Alex] Cuz I need to
get better at marketing
and I know I need to...
So, it's a huge help.
- Well, good, man, that's
what I'm doing it for
and it makes me happy
and I'm glad
you're enjoying it, man.
- [Alex[ Awesome.
I appreciate it, man.
- I hope you have
a great weekend.
Yeah, man, keep at it.
[Alex] - Alright.
Thanks, bud.
- [Woman] You are ridiculous.
(laughing)
(phone dial tone)
- Guys, it's so cool.
(phone dialing)
(voices mumbling)
Your makeup looks great.
- [Woman] Oh, thank you.
Face is Diana, hair is Sarah.
We had like a whole
room set up.
(phone ringing)
- [Gary] Shh! I'm calling Lexi.
(laughing)
- [Lexi] Hello,
Alexandra speaking.
- Hi, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Lexi] Holy shit.
That's awesome.
(group laughter)
- How's it going, Lexi?
- Oh, I've had
better days, Gary,
but I'm keeping on trucking on.
Doing some
remodeling in the house
on a Friday night.
Having some vodka and crans.
- It makes me super
happy to call on a day
that isn't the best of all time.
I hope this adds
to swinging it in
the right direction
for the weekend.
(crowd talking)
- What's that?
- [Tyler] The first kid we've
called is killin' himself.
- Why?
- Oh, the one that hung up?
- What happened?
What happened?
- [Tyler] He's just like,
I fucked everything up.
- Why?
- It's my one shot. I
wanted to talk to him...
- Bro, that was awesome.
He just called me.
But to be honest, I froze.
(Gary laughing)
I love it.
(dial tone)
(phone dialing)
[Mikhail] - Hello,
this is Mikhail.
- Mikhail, this is
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Mikhail] God dammit, man.
(group laughter)
I fucking knew it, too.
I saw the 818 number and
I was like he did a,
hidden phone number
and all this shit.
Have you gotten my--
I sent you over a
Chewbacca mug from 1977.
- Yes I did, man. I did get it.
We got it right? It's
in the office, right?
I saw that.
That's awesome, man.
I really appreciate it.
How are you?
- I'm fucking great.
- Great man.
[Mikhail] Like everything..
That whole crush it, all of it.
I'm doing it. It's awesome.
I can't believe that I'm
on the phone with you.
- That's awesome.
Well, I appreciate it.
You got a good weekend planned?
- [Mikhail] I have
a great weekend.
Actually, I'm so blessed like
one of my clients are
Tech Meetup Palm Springs
and I'm with
their team-building thing.
It's at this amazing spot.
Dual houses and we went
through like vibration rooms
and all this stuff.
I'm sitting here.
I'm like this is my
fucking job, thanks Gary.
- You're welcome.
- [Mikhail] This is you.
- No dude, this is you.
This is you, this was
me for about a second
and you took care of the rest.
- [Mikhail] I think you're right
on that to be honest.
(group laughter)
- I love it, man.
Well listen, I hope you
have the best weekend.
I'm glad we had this moment.
I hope we cross paths again.
I appreciate the Chewbacca cup.
- [Mikhail] Yeah.
No worries man. Have a good one.
- You too. Take care. Bye-Bye.
This is the best.
- The initial reaction
is such a high.
(laughing)
(voices mumbling)
- God dammit, Gary.
(phone dialing)
You might have to play--
You may have to have a clip
that just shows
this whole thing.
It's just maybe that good.
Cocoa Butter Poppy next.
(laughing)
(phone ringing)
This is going to be good.
- [Man On Phone] Hello?
- Yo, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- Holy shoot.
(group laughter)
- What's up my man?
- [Man On Phone] I'm good,
I'm good.
Just getting some work done.
How you doing?
- Getting some work done.
- [Man On Phone] Of course.
Grind non-stop.
- I appreciate the love man.
Thanks for paying attention
enough to put out your number.
- [Man On Phone] Of course,
any time.
- What are you up to? What do
you do?
- I do IT here in Toronto,
so I do a lot of--
I would call it server work,
networking.
Some of my clients
are small businesses
and regular consumers.
- Good for you, man.
- [Man On Phone] Thank you.
- Yeah man. Anything I can
answer for you
while we got this moment?
- Honestly, I wish
I had a question.
Right now my mind is focused
on something else right now.
(laughs)
- No worries.
It's crazy.
Well, no worries. I hope you
have the best weekend man
and a great holiday.
- [Man On Phone] Will do,
Will do.
Can I send you an email?
- Of course.
Gary@VaynerMedia.com.
Send it.
- [Man On Phone] Alright.
Will do. Will do.
Thank you so much.
- Take care.
Alright. Bye-bye.
Good dude.
(phone ringing)
(echoing noise)
- [Christian] Hello?
- Christian.
- [Christian] Yeah.
- It's GaryVee.
- [Christian] Oh snap!
(group laughter)
- How are you?
- [Christian] Good!
Hold on, hold on, hold on.
Hello?
- Hello?
- [Christian] This is
real life GaryVee?
- This is real life GaryVee.
This is me.
- [Christian] What's up?
- Life is good, man.
What's up with you?
- [Christian] Nothing.
Life is great.
- I love it.
Where do you live?
- [Christian] I live in Chicago.
- I love it.
A lot of Chicago love.
I was just in Chicago for
two minutes, the other day.
-  [Christian]Yeah, I've seen.
(laughing)
- When you get a chance,
get out of Tech.
- I know man, I appreciate it.
Thank you for watching the show.
And all the content.
- [Christian] Always.
Thank you for putting it out.
- Of course, man.
Anything I can help
you with real quick?
- [Christian]What makes you
hustle hard every day?
- You know, I'm just
grateful. You know Christian.
I'm just thankful.
Do you know that it--
I don't know if--
Did you see all these
stats running around?
The likelihood of
being a human being
is 440 trillion to one.
- What?
- Uh-huh.
- That's real?
- Yeah. Google it right now.
Do you know how hard it is--
You can win the
mega-millions five times
more likely than actually
becoming a human.
Of course.
You know much sperm is
in your dad's nuts, Nate?
- I don't.
(laughing)
- Well, then you just,
clearly (group laughing).
- Hey, Christian. Listen man.
I hope you have a great
holiday, great Christmas.
Great whatever,
you know, New Years.
All that stuff man.
And I appreciate the love.
- [Christian] Hey, you too.
- Alright man. Take care.
- [Jon] You got to make some
content out of that.
(group laughter)
(group chatter)
- What?
- [Tyler] Like the
equivalent is like
people leaving from Florida
swimming to...
(laughing)
(voices mumbling)
- [Man On Phone 2] How ya
doing Mr. Vaynerchuk?
- Call me Gary.
- [Man On Phone 2] Gary.
- How are things?
- [Man On Phone 2] Good.
- Good man.
Thanks for
putting out your number
and allowing me to say hello.
And thank you for paying
attention to my stuff.
- [Man On Phone 2] Thank you,
I appreciate it.
This is really awesome.
Thank you so much
for the opportunity.
- My pleasure, man.
What's going on?
- [Man On Phone 2] Nothing, just
studying for finals.
- Putting in work?
- [Man On Phone 2] Yep,
(mumbles)
- Alright, good man.
Where do you live?
- [Man On Phone 2] Brisbane,
California.
- Very nice.
I like your snapchat filter,
Twitter icon.
- [Man On Phone 2] Thank you.
- You're welcome, man.
Listen, I hope you have
a great holiday,
a great weekend and
don't study too much.
- [Man On Phone 2] Yes, sir.
- Alright, man,
have a goodnight.
- [Man On Phone 2] Thank you.
Thanks Gary, bye.
(group laughter)
- [Nate] Guys, it's
one in 400 trillion.
- One in 400 trillion?
- [Nate] That's crazy.
- This is what I've been
trying to say, Nate.
It is ridiculously hard
to become a human being,
and then these
mother fuckers complain.
It's you won the greatest lotto,
and then by the way,
let's get real,
a little more serious,
we live in America, right?
I mean, there's a bunch
of white dudes in here.
Thank you for holding it down.
But like, there's that,
people are not
quantifying their luck
and they complain
about dumb shit.
- That's like winning the
lottery three times here.
- [Woman] When you first
said that stat,
I thought it was like,
you could be like a monkey
or like a dog or something.
- Yeah that's where
I was going, yeah.
- That's my thing!
The whole tree,
the Monday morning,
you could've been a bus.
I believe that!
I'm not confused, I know
that a bus is not alive,
but a tree is, a dog is.
- That stat makes
no sense to me.
- Right, 'cause, Nate!
Literally, back to your dad,
literally, your dad,
could've gone up real quick,
and gotten up real quick and
got another glass of water,
and that would've changed
the whole sequence of events,
and you would not exist!
- Gotten another glass of water.
(group laughter)
- He's well hydrated!
- Your dad is
extremely hydrated and
has enormous amounts of sperm!
(group laughter)
Who's gonna get the last one?
(dial tone)
- [Jon] Greatest
DailyVee of all time.
- Let's go with Daniel.
- I truly don't understand
how that even works.
- And now, understand
how awesome this all is.
How lucky are we?
(phone ringing)
- So it's like
I already won the lottery.
- Yes!
That's the point!
People don't--
- I've never thought
about it like that.
- And the fact that
you're with me?
You won the lottery way
more than you think.
- [Danny] Hello?
- Danny?
I'm good man, just calling some
peeps,
thanking them for paying
attention and giving me love.
- [Danny] Oh man, I
appreciate it, that's amazing!
I got goosebumps right now!
- I appreciate it, man.
Anything I can
answer for you real quick?
- [Danny] No, I was the one
who sent you the picture.
I don't know if you
remember, but I tweeted you
I got into a car
accident the other day
and I said you were
with me the whole time.
- I saw that, man, I saw that.
You okay?
- [Danny] Yeah. Yeah, everything
is good.
It was my wife's car, and
it's pretty much totaled,
but yeah everything's good.
- Good, man.
Well, thank God it was
your wife's car, not yours.
I'm just kidding. (laughs)
- [Danny] Yeah, heaven forbid,
right?
- Exactly.
Well, cool man, I wish
you luck in Missouri
and hope you have a great
weekend and great holiday.
- [Danny] Thank you sir,
I appreciate it.
Thank you so much.
- Take care.
- [Danny] It means the
world to me, thank you.
- My pleasure, take care.
- [Danny] Buh-Bye.
- Alright, one more.
- [Man] I was
watching your video
while I was driving and crashed.
(group laughter)
- [DRock] You were with
me the whole time.
- Alright, I gotta go
think about life.
- Right?
No it's a big deal!
This is my whole--
- I've never...
It hasn't crossed my mind.
- [Gary] Right!
So now that you're like,
you feel like you're
being a little more
practical and data'd
out and all this stuff.
- I like data.
- [Gary] You realize
how ridiculous this is?
- [Nate] It's pretty crazy.
- Your life is changed forever.
- Well, it is interesting
to think about things.
- [Gary] No, really I mean.
It's how I think about it.
- [Nate] I've never
thought about it like that.
- It's the only
way to think about it,
like what the fuck is
the matter with people?
- [Nate] Have you guys, like,
ever thought about this?
- Yeah, sure!
How could you not?
- I don't think they thought
about it, by the way.
- [Phil] I absolutely
have thought of it.
- [Nate] I think that I'm
here... I don't think about--
- Well, that's the punchline.
Everybody takes for granted
what they actually have.
And my whole point is,
the entire thing
is what we've taken for granted.
- [Nate] Well, I
know that I'm super lucky.
- But, that's what I mean.
That's easy in the micro,
in the most macro,
it's, you don't
deserve to be here.
And I like to
use the word deserve,
because that makes it like,
it's ridiculous!
It's ridiculous!
The whole thing's ridiculous!
- [Jon] It's also human
nature to think like this,
and not pull up and
think about the fact...
Most people's human nature.
It is.
- Of course!
Why do you think I'm winning?
I've got my shit
in the right perspective,
and you just go!
Like, once you
realize it's all gravy,
it gets real easy.
- Fuck
(group laughter)
- [Everyone] Holy shit.
- It's cool right?
- [Nate] Yeah.
It is good, man,
I'm pumped for you.
It's a big night for you.
(group laughter)
Crush it.
(phone ringing)
- [Man On Phone 3] Hello!
- Yo!
- [Man On Phone 3] Yo!
- It's GaryVee!
- [Man On Phone 3] What's up, G?
- How are you, my man?
- [Man On Phone 3] Hey,
man, I'm good.
Do you remember me?
- I do, yeah, how are things?
I like how all of them
are like he doesn't.
- [Man On Phone 3] I'm so glad
you decided to call me!
- I saw you.
I was wrapping it up and
I saw you in there.
I was like, you know what,
let me just see
what's up with him.
How have you been?
- [Man On Phone 3] Aw, man.
I've been fantastic, man.
I'm here with my two kids.
They're three and
seven right now.
And starting the weekend, man.
- Good for you.
I hope you have a
great, great weekend and
a great holiday.
And I'm glad
you put the number out
so I could say what's up again.
How have you been?
- [Man On Phone 3] I really
appreciate that.
I've been doing good.
I've been building a
brand, and I'm watching
the show and
it's getting me hyped,
and I really have
no excuses man.
I've been following
you since Crush It!
- I know.
- [Man On Phone 3] And I really
appreciate the hustle
that you put in
and the extent to which,
this is what gets me, man,
the detail in which
you document your life,
it's the most amazing thing.
I love #AskGaryVee,
but it's, for me,
DailyVee is the litmus test,
that's where the rubber
meets the road.
- I appreciate it, man.
I hope you and the kids
have a great weekend.
And, I hope
I get to see you soon.
- [Man On Phone 3] You will man,
I'll be in New York soon.
- Alright, man, take care.
- [Man On Phone 3] Take care,
buddy.
- Bye bye. He's a good dude.
- [Man On Phone 4] Let's go
with that one,
not as good as the one before,
but we can
go with that one, too.
- But what's the real one?
- [Man On Phone 4] The Knicks,
I just watched the Knicks,
but I was like,
alright, I can't
do this anymore.
I heard an interview
with Kyle Lowry,
on the, Zach Lowe podcast,
and I was like,
Oh, I kinda like Kyle Lowry.
So I just started
watching the Raptors.
- Yep. And that's it.
- [Man On Phone 4] Not an
insane story,
but it's pretty okay.
- I mean...
yeah.
- [Man On Phone 4] Yeah, dude,
you've helped me
with so much stuff,
just watching
all of your content.
I know you get it a lot, but
you really changed the
way that I look at life,
and the hustle.
- You know what, I do hear it.
And every time I hear it,
it's like the first time
I've heard it.
It means the world to me,
it's the best feeling ever.
I don't know what else to say.
I appreciate it man, thank you.
- [Man On Phone 4] Yeah, tell
Lou I said hi when you see him.
- Lou Geno?
- [Man On Phone 4] Yeah.
- Done, I will.
Is he a Raptor's fan now?
He's a bandwagon in sports, so.
Alright man,
I'll talk to you later.
- [Man On Phone 4] Yeah,
thank you.
- [Tory Ann] Hello?
- Tory Ann?
- [Tory Ann] Oh my gosh!
- It's GaryVee.
- [Tory Ann] Hey!
- How are you?
- [Tory Ann] I'm okay,
how are you doing?
- I'm okay.
What do you mean, okay?
How about you're awesome
or you're super pumped,
or something that gets
me more excited?
- [Tory Ann] Well,
I'm super pumped that
I'm on the phone with you.
That's for a 100% sure.
- Okay good.
What do you got
going on this weekend?
- [Tory Ann] I'm working,
I don't know, I'm doing
this job right now--
- And it's
pissing you off, right?
- [Tory Ann] Yes!
- [Voice Message] You've
reached Alejandra Perez,
if there's any questions,
leave your name and number,
thank you!
- This is going to be good.
(beep)
- Ali, it's GaryVee.
I tried you, I'm really
sad we couldn't connect.
Hope you have the best day ever.
(dial tone)
- That's gonna hurt.
(phone dialing)
What the voicemail?
(laughs)
It's gonna hurt right?
- [Jon] It's gonna hurt.
- Aw man.
If that's voicemail's like,
it's Macho Man Randy Savage
GaryVee, just wanna say hey.
I'll be like no.
(group laughter)
I loved him so much.
- [Man 3] Well we're live.
(indiscernible chatter
amongst group)
- [Gretchen] Hello?
- Gretchen?
- [Gretchen] Yeah.
- This is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Gretchen] Oh my gosh.
- How are you?
- [Gretchen] I'm good,
how are you?
- I'm great, you told
me to holla at ya girl
and I did.
(group laughter)
- [Gretchen] (laughing)
I'm so glad.
- How are things,
are you Nashville?
- [Gretchen] Yes I am.
- You got a
good weekend planned?
- [Gretchen] Probably,
actually I'm really focused
on my blog right now.
- Good, I love the hustle.
- [Gretchen] Yeah, you're
inspiring me as usual.
- Good, well thanks for being
point of the 60 Second Club.
- [Gretchen] Thank you,
thanks for calling.
- No worries.
- [Gretchen] How much time do I
have?
- You have another
60 seconds, let's go.
- [Gretchen] (laughing) Alright
so, gosh where do I start?
As far as all of the
different media channels,
I've really been
focusing on Instagram.
- Smart.
So one thing real quick, your
Twitter is linked to your
blog, I would put
it to your Instagram,
the Get Healthy 615.
I would make that
link to your Instagram
if you're really
focused on Instagram,
I would use the chess
pieces to move it all there
and then
amplify from there, okay?
- [Gretchen] Okay.
- I just followed you on
Twitter so I'll start seeing
some of your stuff.
Miguel said to Chad saying
just hung up on me because
my cofounder Miguel
said that's funny,
you should've picked up.
Chad goes, Miguel,
I picked up, GaryVee was chill
until LL Coolzay shit the bed.
(group laughter)
This is amazing.
- [Jon] Then he cut him off.
That was fucked up.
Yes.
- [Tyler] Mads, how's it going?
(dial tone)
- Good how are you guys?
- [Gary] Mads.
(indiscernible chatter
from group)
- [Jessica] Hello?
- Jessica?
- [Jessica] Gary.
- How are you?
- [Jessica] I'm great,
how are you?
- Good what's going on?
- [Jessica] Not much
just got home from work.
- And how was that?
- [Jessica] Fantastic, I
get to do something I love
and I wasn't even working
in TV a year ago
and I've worked on eight
TV shows this year.
- That's amazing.
- [DRock] Get it.
(laughter)
- [Jessica] Yeah you
mentioned Empire in your video
the other day and I was like
hell yeah to the Empire.
- I love it, I appreciate
putting your phone number
out and giving me
a chance to say hello
and thank you for paying
attention to my stuff.
- It's GaryVee.
- [Matt] Aw shit,
what's up, man?
- What up man how are you?
- [Matt] I'm good baby.
What's going on?
- What's going on with you?
- [Matt] I'm just about
to go ice skating
with my lady.
Yo shout out Tyler Schmitt dog.
- [Gary] That's the only
reason you're on man,
Schmidt made it happen.
- [Matt] That's my guy
right there man.
- Like your guy like
your best friend or...
- [Matt] I mean that dude's
the bull right there man.
(group laughter)
I hope you're
treating him well up there.
- I'm treating him well,
this is the greatest thing
that has ever happened in
this mother fucker's life.
(group laughter)
- [Matt] Just give him a
raise dog or some shit.
- [Gary] I'm actually about to
give him a pay cut cause
I don't like his attitude.
(DRock laughs)
- [Matt] Oh hey I'm sorry.
(group laughter)
- I'm kidding.
- [Tyler] 'Sup Matt!
- [Matt] (indiscernible) your
boy bro.
- Matty have a
great holiday, man.
- [Matt] Yeah, peace guys.
Have a good one.
- Get your ice skating.
- [Tyler] What's up Matt?
(dial tone)
(group laughter)
- [Henry On Phone] Henry.
- Henry it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Henry] (laughing) yo dog.
- How are you man?
- [Henry] Life is good.
I cannot complain.
T Schmidty what's going on?
- [Tyler] Oh Henry what up?
(group laughter)
What's cooking?
- This is all about Schmidt.
- [Henry] Oh man this is crazy.
- How's life?
- [Henry] Hey man I can't
complain at all.
Life is great.
- Good man.
- [Tyler] Henry he
called, (indiscernible)
- I'm just calling all of
Tyler's friends and telling them
how bad Tyler's doing here.
(laughter)
- [Henry] I heard some
dude did shout out Tyler
on his Facebook Live
like two minutes ago.
- And now it's your turn man.
Hey listen,
have a great holiday alright?
- [Henry] Alright you too, Gary.
- Alright man.
Luke.
(dial tone)
It's so crazy how much you
and your sister look alike.
I'm just looking at
you I was like, my god,
like at Super Bowl
when she came over,
she's like do you know who I am?
I'm like yes.
You are Madelana's sister.
- [Luke's Voicemail] Hi this is
Luke.
- [Voicemail Machine] At
the tone, please record
- your message.
- Air conditioning?
When you've finished
recording, you may hang up,
or press one for more options.
- HVAC.
- [Nate] HVAC.
(voicemail beeps)
- Hey Luke, so listen,
here's my problem,
my work is on fire and
I need air conditioning
so (laughing) I love
for you to call me back.
Hey Luke, it's GaryVee,
Trouty gave me your number
I just wanna say what's
up for all the love.
Hope your holiday is phenomenal.
Hope I get to meet you soon,
come through the office.
See ya.
(group laughter)
(dial tone)
(indiscernible chatter
from group)
(laughing) My work is on fire.
- [Man On Phone 5] Hello?
- Hello this is Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Man On Phone 5] Hi,
Gary Vaynerchuk.
- How are you?
- [Man On Phone 5] Oh shit.
(group laughter)
- What's going on?
- [Man On Phone 5] I am good,
I'm fantastic.
- Well good man, thanks
for putting out your number
and allowing me
to say what's up.
- [Man On Phone 5] Wow, aw man.
I have all your books.
- I appreciate that.
What's that?
- [Nate] It was going to be
one more like 50 people ago.
I can't stop.
- [Tyler] Why?
What'd you want him to do, Nate?
- [Nate] Nothing.
- I can't stop!
- [Nate] This is great.
- [Jon] Did you want to talk
about 400 trillion people more?
- [Nate] I'm still super
thrown off by that.
Did you know that
the probability of you
being here is
like 1 in 400 trillion?
What? In this
room with him right now?
(group laughter)
- [Gary] No, you being born.
- [Nate] No you being born is
like one in 400 trillion.
- [Madelena] Oh, no.
Where do we know that from?
- [Phil] Gary.
- [Nate] Statistics.
- Is that what he tells you?
- [Gary] No, this is real.
- [Nate] I looked it up too.
- [Madelana] Oh I get it.
(dial tone)
(phone dialing)
(indiscernible speaking
from group)
- You got it.
- [Man 5] Yes, she watches.
- [Gary] It's just true.
Do you know how crazy this is?
- [Nate] I didn't understand.
(phone ringing)
(laughter)
- [Gary] Oh but the numbers
compound like crazy.
- [Patty] Hello?
- Hey it's Gary Vaynerchuk,
how are you Patty?
- [Patty] Hey how are you?
- Good what's going on?
- [Patty] Not much,
I was actually watching
your Youtube videos
and I thought
I would follow you on Twitter,
and then I saw your Tweet
so I sent you a number.
- Well I appreciate it.
- [Patty] (laughing)
Thank you, I appreciate you
for calling me.
- Patty, I'm scared right now.
- [Patty] Why?
- You're a Dolphins'
fan aren't you?
- [Patty] I am, I am.
-Fuck.
- Born and raised Miami,
so I am Dolphins, Heat, Marlins.
- I knew it, I knew it.
Alright, well that's
alright, it is what it is.
I hope you have a great holiday,
I'm glad we got to connect.
- [Patty] You too,
thanks for calling me.
- Alright, bye bye.
- [Patty] Bye.
- That was fun.
That was a good sesh,
that was fun.
- [Madelena] Is that something
new that you do now?
- I used to do it way back
in the day, on Ustream
back in 2009,
Phil tried to get in.
- [Nate] And Spreecast.
- [Gary] And Spreecast.
Calling people's so fun,
it's just great.
- [Madelena] I mean the
holy shit is the best part.
- [Nate] Holy hell.
- [Phil] There's a really
good God damn.
- [Group] Oh, goddammit Gary!
- [Nate] The 400 trillion people
thing is just like...
- [Phil] Not people.
-[Nate] Not people, chances
is a crazy amount of...
- [Gary] Nate.
- The denominator is so big.
- This is what I've
been trying to tell you.
And then I layer on the fact
that I wasn't born in America,
so first of all it was
impossible, then I end up
in fucking Soviet Union, right,
and then, after
80 years or 60 years
or 70, something,
you know, 65 years
of Cold War hardcore Communism,
there's a moment in
time that allows me
to leave Soviet Russia,
come to America, like
- [Nate] I just don't, I just
hadn't thought about it like
- [Madelena] What
are those odds?
- Oh, my...
- [Madelena] And now you're
here calling people.
- [Nate] I don't even know
what's after trillions?
- You know what,
I'm calling Johnny.
Because the odds of Johnny
getting this phone call
were actually zero,
he had no chance, but now,
because Nate kept sitting on
this incredible feeling,
he inspired me to call Johnny.
And watch what happens.
- [Nate] Johnny doesn't answer.
- That's exactly it.
(group laughter)
(phone rings)
- [Madelena] Huge
mistake, Johnny.
- [Johnny] Hello?
- Johnny?
- [Johnny] Yessir!
- It's Gary Vaynerchuk.
- [Johnny] What's going
on man, how are you?
- I'm phenomenal, how 'bout you?
- [Johnny] It's Vaynerchuk.
I'm sittin' here, having a drink
with my fiance and a friend.
- Well great.
- [Johnny] I saw your
tweet and thought
I'd throw it out there.
- Well I love it, it worked.
And Nate, Nate here
made me make this call
because he's so blown away that
it's one in 400 trillion
chance of becoming a human,
that he's feeling the glow,
and I stopped calling,
but I got motivated,
and I called one more person,
and Johnny, it is you that made
that call, or got that call.
- [Johnny] I appreciate that.
- And I hope you
have a phenomenal,
phenomenal, phenomenal holiday.
- [Johnny] We will,
man, you too.
I hope things go well
with Xander and Misha
and the wife and everything.
- Thank you very much, Johnny.
Take care, man.
- [Nate] You're welcome, Johnny.
- [Johnny] Sounds good, man.
We'll see ya.
- He could care less
about your impact, Nate.
(group laughter)
- He really didn't care.
- He gave you
zero point zero love.
- This guy caught his
reaction to the call.
(whistling)
So why can't
I turn off the radio?
I'm so sick of love songs.
- [Man] I'm gonna be dead.
- [Gary] No, I know.
You were still here.
- [Nate] That was
the worst fucking ...
(group laughter)
(soft piano music)
- Do you know how
amazing this will be
for us to look back at?
Nate, you know how fun--
(group laughter)
Wow.
- [Man In Christmas Suit] Hello
there.
- That is incredible.
- How's it going?
- [Gary] You look great.
That's amazing.
Did you get that suit?
- [DRock] Yeah, I got it.
- Do you know how fun
it would be if DailyVee
was around from the beginning?
(hip hop music)
- Like the episode
where I told Trou
in the middle of the street
that he had to
decide his life's future?
Or those episodes where Phil
was undermining Nate's career,
(group laughter)
didn't set him up for success.
- [Gary] Nate, why are you
not able to do anything?
Phil really wanted the job back,
it was a year too early.
- Yeah, Nate,
put him on the aisle seat?
- [Jon] It just goes to
show how good you were.
You overcame all odds.
- [Nate] Something like that.
- [Gary] Who'd you train, Playa?
- [Nate] I didn't fuck up
everything.
- [Gary] No.
- [Man] Is this us?
- [Tyler] They trained me.
- [Jon] This is us.
- [Gary] No I know that.
- [Tyler] To be AJ's assistant.
- [Nate] No, it was Playa.
- [Gary] It was, right?
- [Nate] We also trained Tyler.
- [Tyler] He wanted to
throw that in there.
(group laughter)
- [Nate] I'm still unsubscribed
from emails for Gary, so.
- [Gary] I know, thank you Nate.
All right, all right.
Hey guys!
Hi!
- Welcome.
- Thank you.
- We're like,
are we the welcome wagon?
- Change up nicely.
You guys look nice.
- Thank you!
- I'm Charlie.
- Charlie, Gary. How are you?
- I'm good, how are you?
- Really nice to meet you.
- Nice to meet you.
- How are things?
Is this it?
So cool.
(electronic music)
Is this our studio?
- [DRock] Yeah.
- You've seen it before?
- [DRock] No.
- It's cool, right?